[Music]
I'm going to paradise just for Colton
well we know you went to paradise what
can you tease for us about how things
went we've seen you in tears in the
trailer what was it like to see Tia
again
it was very emotional because I think
you know I'm just coming out of a
relationship with Becca and I'm dealing
with Tia at the same time and I'm also
on a beach with a bunch of beautiful
women and some of my friends so I wasn't
expecting to feel the emotions that I
felt I mean there are feelings for Tia
you know I think you're gonna have to
tune in to find out and see see what
exactly I mean by that you I have to say
is there a little bit of frustration
there because especially watching back
the episode it seems like Tia talking
about played a part in her decision were
you a little frustrated with Tia and
have you talked any that out yeah you
know I think frustration is a good word
to use mad is not I'm not mad at SIA cuz
that's how she felt and I'm proud that
she you know she risked her friendship
with Becca to come back and talk and
speak her truth so I can't you know I
can't say I'm mad at her but I am
frustrated and I am a little confused
because you know the last I saw of Tia
was at the spa date when we all you know
we're on the same page and she was
wishing me well on my journey and you
know it just didn't play out the way
that I thought I was gonna play out when
was last time you guys talked have you
talked since that episode aired where we
saw Becca send you home after talking it
to you I did reach out and message to
you after that episode and just let her
know where I stood you know I wasn't mad
I was just frustrated I was confused she
says she knows where I stand
have you seen any haters who might say
were you an opportunist going on this
show who questioned that you thought T
might be the battery life you know
anybody who questions intentions of
going on the show I think for me you
know I put myself out there I was true
to who I was and there was no plotting
there was no scheming it was just me
going on a show and I feel like it was
so good for me to do this so I'm happy
with how everything played out and I
love I love everybody
have there been talks for you to be the
bachelor because a lot of fans are
asking you know I think that you're
gonna have to see how paradise plays out
and there's gonna be you know times if
the timing is right in my life and if
ABC is ready for it it would be
something that you know I would consider
but first we're gonna have to get
through paradise are you glad you want
on paradise I'm very happy that I went
on paradise why
because I think you could tell in the
last episode there's a lot of
conversations I need to be had and it
was also another time for me to put
myself out there and and you know take a
shot at finding love and you know dating
other other women
[Music]